there's rising alarm at the flight of
Europe's Jews from the continent not
just because of recent terrorist attacks
in Belgium and France and stabbings
elsewhere but also the rise of
anti-semitism in 1991 the Jewish
population in the EU was two million 25
years later it's 1.4 million if Europe
allows anti-semitism to flourish that
will be the beginning of the end of
Europe Lord sacks was the key speaker
during a special conference at
Parliament addressing the predicament of
Europe's Jewish communities Jewish life
is an essential part of our cultural
identity Europe is not Europe without
Jewish heritage layup do a song as we
politic money people came and pour leur
guarantee revenue for spare apt-get path
and his reign car in SS tompa portege
easy among the speakers the renowned
french intellectual burner on real fa la
hora de vivre new episode we are annette
a victim le reve de oro de el sol
awkwardly team is only less yo vivo de
parada team may so book brutally implode
sax made this impassioned plea to any
peace you are the leaders of Europe its
future is in your hands if you do
nothing Jews will leave European Liberty
will die and there will be a moral stain
on Europe's name that all eternity will
not erase stop it now while there is
still time thank
Oh